Roads, roads go everywhere.
Roads go here, and roads go there.
Look at the road.
What do you see?
I see a road going around corners.
Twisting and turning, the road goes on.
It winds around and around.
Roads go through the country.
They go to big cities.
Look at the road.
What do you see?
I see a road going up the hill.
I see a road going down the hill.
Like a roller coaster, the road goes up and down.
Roads go over mountains.
They go through forests.
Look at the road.
What do you see?
I see a road going into the tunnel.
I see a road coming out of the tunnel.
In and out of the tunnel, the road keeps going.
Roads cross over rivers.
They are on bridges.
Look at the road.
What do you see?
I see a road that goes nowhere.
I see a road that just stops.
Wow, it is a dead end.